today on the matt wall show as the
derrick chauvin trial continues we'll
try to sort through all of the issues
related to
george floyd's death was he actually
murdered did it have anything to do with
race and
however he died does he deserve to be
memorialized and celebrated nationwide
these are three separate questions that
all need to be dealt with separately
also five headlines including
another vicious anti-asian assault
that's being blamed on white supremacy
even though it wasn't carried out by a
white person small technicality there
plus
youtube makes a move to protect the
feelings of youtube creators like myself
and i really appreciate that
because my feelings are fragile and aoc
says you're racist if you use the term
border surge
all of that plus our daily cancellation
and much more today on the matt walsh
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
centuries from now as archaeologists of
the future sift through the rubble
of our collapsed civilization i wonder
what they'll think when they uncover all
the statues memorials
murals to an ancient historical figure
named george floyd
if they're very perceptive they may even
note that hundreds of monuments to other
figures were torn down around the time
that floyd's monuments went up sometimes
the latter directly replacing the former
they'll conclude i imagine that floyd
was some kind of
history-shaping leader pioneer hero
i think he was a great man perhaps one
of the greatest men to ever live
this assumption will be understandable
given the evidence yet totally wrong
george floyd we know was not a great man
or a good man or even a passively decent
man
he was a violent felon and a drug addict
celebrated as a martyr based entirely on
the manner of his death which
whatever else you might think about it
was not exactly heroic itself
the conversation around this man
especially now that the trial
of the cop charged in his death has
begun and will drag on probably for
weeks
that conversation is hopelessly
convoluted there are really three
separate conversations that have since
last may
been blended together as one there's the
conversation about the manner of floyd's
death was he
murdered by derek shoving and the
conversation about floyd's race and how
it related to his death
if he was murdered was it racially
motivated and the conversation about
floyd's posthumous elevation
to the status of folk hero whether he
was murdered or not
whether it was racially motivated or not
is it good for us to celebrate this man
and plaster his face
all over our cities in his memory for
the media on the left this
is all one discussion with only one
acceptable point of view
yes floyd was murdered yes he was the
victim of racism and yes
he should be mourned and honored by all
people everywhere through all time
to them the final two propositions flow
automatically from the first if you ask
them
you know why we should honor george
floyd they'll say
well because he was murdered by a police
officer if he asked them how they know
he was the victim of racism they'll say
well it's because he was murdered by a
police officer
if you ask them how they know he was
murdered by a police officer they'll
just spit in your face and refuse to
dignify the question with an answer
this is why you cannot criticize the
hero worship of george floyd without
being accused of
defending the officer who allegedly
killed him they don't see a distinction
between his death and the hero worship
it's all part of a package
you're required to believe that floyd
was murdered
and that it was because of racism and
that he deserves to be honored in death
in the way that we honor civil rights
pioneers and war heroes
to stray from that narrative on any one
of those points
is to reject them all now of course in
reality
you might really reject them all and
there's nothing wrong with that
though it'll send the left in his into
hysterics who cares but the point is
that
one need not reject them all in order to
reject one
or two of them these are again different
conversations
different points of contention different
things entirely
as to my own view i think it is going to
be very difficult to prove that george
floyd was murdered given the fact that
he had chosen to put lethal doses of a
dangerous narcotic
into his system before he died if he had
not taken those drugs
and then resisted arrest resisted we
should note repeatedly and frantically
over the course of several minutes
he would most likely be alive today
floyd was also complaining that he
couldn't breathe
before he was on the ground and
restrained the prosecution will have to
prove
not only that chauvin's actions were
negligently homicidal but that floyd
died from those actions and not from the
drugs
they haven't proved it yet we'll see if
they can
now i tend to hold the increasingly
controversial view that
murder cases should be decided in court
and that
both sides should be heard from before a
verdict is decided
as to the other questions these are much
clearer to me
no george floyd's death had nothing to
do with racism
there is simply no evidence not even the
hint of evidence that derek chovin was
motivated by any racial animus
at all there is no evidence not even the
hint of evidence
that shelvin would have acted
differently had floyd been white instead
of black
there's also no evidence that police are
more likely to kill an unarmed black
suspect
more unarmed white suspects are killed
each year by police and when you examine
the statistical likelihood
that the arrest that's what you have to
look that's how you have to look at this
the likelihood that the arrest of an
unarmed black suspect will turn
fatal versus the statistical likelihood
that the arrest of a white suspect will
turn fatal
you're going to find that they are
almost exactly the same
also you'll find that the category of
unarmed suspect is misleading in the
extreme as
much of the time the unarmed person
quote unquote was nonetheless in the
process of trying to kill the police
officer
through some other means sometimes by
trying to take the officer's gun and use
it against
the the racial element of the george
floyd saga is a fabrication
it is not based on anything other than
the left's blanket
assumptions which they apply to all
police killings indiscriminately
if a black man is killed by the cops no
matter the circumstance it was because
of racism
that's what they think 10 years ago i
may have been exaggerating had i
summarized their position that way
but not anymore that is really what they
think
finally should we be celebrating george
floyd
this again to me is clear-cut no we
should not whether you believe he was
the
victim of murder or manslaughter or his
own choices or some combination of these
the fact remains that it's a disgrace
and embarrassment to our country to have
this man's face and likeness plastered
everywhere
it is gross to give a man like this an
elaborate funeral
a golden casket visited by weeping
dignitaries from across the country
remember the mayor of
minneapolis breaking down it you can't
even can't contain
breaking down in tears you know as if he
was at the fu
the casket of his own child or something
the way that he was
the way that he was reacting it's insane
to spend a year mourning his death while
thousands of other people have died in
the meantime
and the vast majority of them were far
more deserving of our tears than floyd
again this is the case no matter how he
died because the manner of his death
does not change the fact that this was a
man who preyed
on members of his own community he was a
violent man a career criminal
predator who should be alive today
simply because he never should have been
allowed out of prison
after he invaded a woman's home put a
gun to her stomach and robbed her
another man in floyd's group pistol
whipped during the process
i mean think about that but not not just
breaking into someone's house no no
forcing your way in at gunpoint
pistol-whipping a woman this wasn't a
youthful mistake but an act of barbaric
cruelty
committed by a then 33 year old hardened
criminal
and after serving an absurdly short
sentence for that crime i think he
served maybe six or seven years
or less he was released from prison now
the media tells us he cleaned up his act
at that point but it's odd that a
reformed man with a cleaned up act
would be high on fatal levels of
fentanyl while attempting to scam a
local store clerk with counterfeit bills
you know
that to me doesn't sound like
reformation
does any of this matter in assessing the
facts
surrounding his death no none of it but
potentially the fentanyl
matters for that it does however matter
in deciding whether
floyd should be canonized that's where
it matters
and it's clear that he should not be or
i should say should not have been
because it's already happened and this
point matters it's not semantics
we're not picking a dead man's life
apart for no reason normally
this is not a conversation that i would
want to have i don't relish the
opportunity
to point out the sins of the dead i'm
not going to find any random person
their obituary in the newspaper and
start examining and pointing out all the
bad things they did
is that what i want to do is how i ought
to spend my time but when you paint
giant murals of him
and rename streets after him then it
becomes necessary to think about the
kind of message that might send
now the irony here is that the left
certainly agrees with this in principle
because
they're the ones who've torn down
hundreds of statues of dead men
based on the alleged sins those men
committed
for floyd we have to ask do we want our
children to grow up in a world where a
violent felon
who victimized women and stole from and
robbed his neighbors is celebrated
and put forward as an example all
because he died while resisting arrest
and high on drugs
i would say no we don't at least i don't
i want my kids to aim a little higher in
life than that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from rex md you know
men's health doesn't get much attention
that's partly our fault
guys because we don't like going to the
doctor i know i don't like going to the
doctor and we definitely don't like
talking about sensitive issues
here's the thing a lot of men's health
issues have really simple solutions we
don't find out about them because we're
not going to the doctor
rexmd.com is here for that rex md makes
getting prescription ed medications easy
all done online and from the comfort of
of your home then
delivered no office visits no talking to
a receptionist
super simple right now sample packs of
eating medications are available for
listeners of my show and i'll tell you
how to get those in a second so it's
simpler than ever to get started here's
how it works
you'll fill out a quick medical
questionnaire on their website and a
doctor refuser situation prescribes you
the ed medication
that you need if appropriate then your
medication is shipped right to your door
with free two-day shipping
it's fast transparent and affordable
half of men experience ed after the age
of 40 and that's that's that may sound
scary but it's a fact
it's way more common than a lot of
people realize which is why rex md chief
medical officer dr tony papolo believes
so strongly in what they're doing guys
are getting
better performance quickly and
conveniently with rex md so it's never
been easier to take control of your
health
these sample pack prescriptions i
mentioned are available at rexmd.com
walsh so go to rex rex md
dot com slash walsh to get started with
rexmd rexmd.com
walsh you know we're experiencing kind
of a contentious moment in our household
um which i share with you because why
wouldn't i just share it with a bunch of
strangers
you know i went into my my daughter's
room uh this this morning before i left
for work
to say uh say bye to earth i always do
and she um
she told me that she had she had lost a
tooth the night before
and she didn't she didn't tell us that
she had lost the tooth
because she was she was running a test
she's a smart girl she's smart
and she was running a test she's like
daddy
i lost the tooth i didn't tell you she
was she was running a test because she
wanted to see
like yeah the tooth fairy comes
allegedly
but if i don't tell mommy and daddy that
i lost a tooth will the tooth fairy
still come
because the tooth fairy should still
come if the tooth fairy exists even if
mom and daddy don't know about it
tooth fairy should know and so she told
me that night you know i'm kind of like
scrambling and i'm like well
yeah well we we communicate with the
tooth fairy or something i don't know we
have to send her an email
i just try to think of excuse and of
course the whole time i'm thinking in my
head like what
why are we doing this this has been my
point all along
if i could go back and redo one thing
as a parent go back to the beginning it
would probably be this i don't think i
would do the
the fantasy i don't think i i think i
might not introduce
tooth fairy santa easter bunny all that
and the problem is or maybe you pick one
like just do santa not the others
because the problem is now they're a
package
and the tooth fairy is a lot more
frivolous than santa and it feels not as
important
and also somehow even weirder and
crazier and harder for kids to believe
like they're going to figure out
tooth fairy before they figure out santa
but now it's a package
so i was talking my wife about it she's
like oh we can't tell her about tooth
fairy because then santa goes and
i want to get another christmas out of
that
it's uh it's not it's not worth the
trouble and then you're just lying to
your kid's face about it
all for what all for what is what i ask
all right let's move on number one here
from the new york post says a racist
attacker brutally beats an asian woman
who was walking to her church
in midtown on monday morning maybe
you've seen this let's play the clip
right here
uh this is looks like security camera
footage
um the woman walking just she's walking
down the street and then the guy comes
up
kicks her it's a horrible footage
stop me stomping on her head could
easily have killed her
is trying to kill her and then probably
the most disturbing thing you see in the
video
you see at the very end there are two
guys standing there watching all this
happen
and it looks like at the very end
i mean literally insult to injury the
guy starts shutting the door
and leaving this woman this uh what's a
65 year old woman
bleeding on the sidewalk
um now for the new york post report here
the uh the guy yelled at the woman f you
you don't belong here
so this was it would seem really clearly
uh in
anti-asian hate crimes oh that's what
he's being charged with
and from what i read the hotel staff
also have been
put on leave uh for just standing by and
watching
and i'm you know and i'm not gonna make
any excuses for them at all
because when you watch something like
this happening your duty is to step in i
don't want to hear any
yeah this is this guy that was doing
this a big guy you know you might think
i don't know if i can take it so what
you got to step in it's one of those
times
even if you get yourself hurt in the
process you have to step in it's your
responsibility as a man as another human
it's your responsibility to step in but
we also
have created a situation as a society
where we discourage
people now after the fact yeah we blame
people who don't step in and again we
should they we should blame them for
because they should because
they ought to step in but we've also
created a situation
where we're discouraging people from
stepping in because
you know the whole hotel staff might
start thinking well you know if i step
in if
i am i going to get sued am i are they
going to start
saying that i'm a racist am i going to
get blamed for this
am i going to get fired there are plenty
of cases of
employees in different establishments
retail stores trying to stop someone
from stealing then they get fired for
doing it somebody gotta get five really
they they're running through all that in
their head
still you gotta do the right thing even
in spite of that but we haven't exactly
created a situation as a society
where people really are encouraged to um
to do the right thing in these
situations now
an update on this story the attacker's
name
is brandon elliott
i want to read this to you he is
he he's out walking the streets or he
was walking the streets
because he was off on parole after
killing his mother
in 2002. now
he killed his own mother uh and he would
have been i think he's 38 now
it would have been his early 20s when he
did this now that is a sentence that
just
should not ever need to be written
that's a sentence that shouldn't exist
on parole after killing his mother
that is not a sentence that should ever
be published
because that's not a thing that should
ever happen there is no situation
where anyone should ever see the outside
of a prison
of a prison after killing their own
parents
no what we should be reading about with
uh brandon elliott is we should be
reading
uh you know the state carried out an
execution of
brandon elliot like that should be the
headline of brandon elliot
his execution for killing his own mother
at the very least you keep him in prison
you want to talk about prison reform
rather than then
i know the prison reform that we got
from donald trump supposedly the law and
order candidate the law and order
president right
um the present form we got from from him
was about letting people out of prison
and it made kim kardashian really happy
so that's nice that prison reform made
kim kardashian happy
great but that's not the kind of prison
reform that's going to stop
things like this from happening that's
not the kind of prison reform that's
going to make our community safer
the kind of prison reform we need is
where you do something like murder your
mother
or murder anybody you never get out of
jail
automatically you are in jail forever
you never see the
that is a once not we don't get three
strikes not ten
one strike and you're out you kill
someone you're in prison forever
if not at a minimum you're in prison
forever
um you do something like what he just
did brutally assault someone
randomly for no reason when they're
walking down the street
in prison forever
when you do that there are things that
you can do as a person
where you are announcing to society
that you have no interest in being a
part of it
you don't want to be a part of civilized
society you want to be
an animal that's what you want
and so we have no choice if we want to
protect the innocent
we have no choice but to say okay you
want to be treated like an animal
that's what you're asking for that's
what you'll get now you're going to be
in a cage for the rest of your life
if we're not forced to put you down like
a dog
through your own behavior we have no ch
we have no choice
you got a guy like brandon elliott what
choice do we have
he's making exceedingly clear he kills
his own mother we let him out of prison
then he just starts attacking random
elderly people
what does brandon elliott have to do to
get the message across
i don't want to be a person i want to be
an animal
let me out of jail i'm going to keep
victimizing people
what does the court system say well okay
we'll give you another chance
yes i mean you start by killing your
mother you spend 17 18 years in prison
and magically you're going to be better
now
it's probably not you spend 17 18 years
hanging out with other violent
sociopaths you're probably not going to
be
you're not going to be less dangerous
now than you were when you went in
and if you are really here's the thing
if you are really reformed
the way i see it like if if if you do
something like that
and then you go to the parole board and
you ask to be led out of prison
that to me is an indication that you're
not reformed
because if you were reformed actual
reformation would be
um yeah you know i've realized the error
in my ways and i realized that i deserve
to be here i don't deserve to be out
in in society i deserve this punishment
the fact that you think you deserve to
get out of jail after doing something
like that tells me that you are not
reformed
that you are still the violent sociopath
you were 17 years ago
18 years ago whatever
um but even so even after that attack
we're still told that
you know now brandon elliott as uh not
as a black man not a white man
um even though this is still white
supremacy of course as you might expect
eugene goo dr eugene goo
is a prominent leftist crackpot on
social media he's got a big following
and uh half a million followers in fact
he sent out a tweet that said
it was after this uh this story broke he
said black on asian crimes only occur
because of our system of white supremacy
that strips african americans of their
economic opportunities
while taking respected dignity away from
asian americans also
white people in power are experts at
dividing and conquering to stay in power
oh okay
oh you see that's why brandon elliott
stomped an elderly asian woman half to
death it's because he didn't have
economic opportunities that's also why
he killed his mother
because of white supremacy
that is this logic is not only insane
and twisted
um but it also strikes me as incredibly
racist
that you're taking asia uh agency away
from black americans
what he's what he's saying here um
pretty clearly is uh he couldn't help
himself
can't expect him we can't expect him to
not act that way
that's what he's saying that to me is
racist
the not racist approach is to say i
don't care if you're white black or
i don't care what your color is you act
like that you're going to jail forever
it is your fault 100 it's on you
we expect you to act like a civilized
person if you can't
you're going to prison the race is
irrelevant
all right number two um on the subject
of white supremacy that's a subject
every day of course
uh even though they're about they're
about 12 white supremacists
in the country but um this is what we
have to worry about is white supremacy
is the major problem
so aoc had some thoughts about the surge
at the border um
which we're not supposed to call it that
but she had some thoughts on it which
she shared on
on instagram and here it is they want to
say
what about the surge well
first of all just gut check
stop anyone who's using the term surge
around you consciously is trying to
invoke
a militaristic frame and that's a
problem
because these this is not a surge
these are children and they are not
insurgents
and we are not being invaded which by
the way
is a white supremacist
idea philosophy the idea that
if an other is coming in the population
that this is like an invasion of who we
are
yeah white supremacists right because
white people invented that
that people who are on the outside of
your group your tribe
are in other and when they come they're
invading
that's a white supremacist idea
huh is that isn't that we here for the
native american groups all the time
do we always hear about the european
invasion of the americas so that's white
supremacy it's white supremacist to say
that about white people
well but of course not in that case it's
not because we know that the term whites
are
you i i i still hear somehow
normal sane rational people even
conservatives using the term white
supremacy
you know as if it still means something
you got to just stop using that word
you know because you're you're you're
accepting the left's framework
the word now it doesn't mean anything
anymore it just doesn't you can't use it
it has no meaning white supremacy now is
whatever they don't like is white
supremacy
that's that's all it means they have
they have
stripped it of of any other meaning
by the way serge she says it's your uh
your consciously
if you use the word surge consciously
as opposed to what using it
unconsciously
but if you use it consciously then
you're uh it's a militaristic white
supremacist
framework she says well the the
definition of according to the
dictionary definition of surge is a
sudden powerful forward or upward
movement especially by a crowd or by a
natural force
such as the waves are tied
uh a crowd or a natural force moving
suddenly and powerfully forward or
upward okay so it's
when uh when you've got a crowd of
people who are
suddenly moving in a certain direction
that's what surge means
got a crowd of people moving in a
certain direction so like let's say for
example
a crowd of illegal immigrants moving
up north
it's almost like what would you call
that a surge i don't know
number three this is from tube filter
which is apparently a website it says
in what would mark a major change to the
way in which viewers can engage with
youtube videos if permanently
implemented
the platform is testing a new display
whereby video
dislike counts wouldn't be publicly
shown
youtube announced on twitter that the
experiment is being conducted among a
small group of users
and was conceived quote in response to
creator feedback around
well-being and targeted dislike
campaigns
while dislikes won't be publicly
displayed or participat
for participants in the test creators
will still be able to see the exact
number of likes and dislikes on their
videos on the back end in youtube
studio um in a help forum post youtube
clarified that there is no way to opt
out of the experiment though it says
the move isn't permanent and that's
keeping a close eye on feedback so
uh what they're saying is that you know
when when you're when you're making
youtube videos like much like i do
and you get a bunch of dislikes it's it
is it is uh damaging to your well-being
to your psychological and emotional
well-being
and you know what at first i saw this i
thought that this is ridiculous but then
i realized hey i'm a youtube creator
and it hurts my feelings when i get
dislikes how dare you
i spent all my time putting these videos
out there
and for you to not like it
you're entitled to like it i mean i made
it
how dare you not like it you ungrateful
bastards
i'm in favor of this i think it should
be really
instead of getting rid of the dislike
button it should be a like button and
another like button so you get two
choices but you can like it or you can
or maybe like
you can like it or you can love it those
are your two options
i think that that's what we should go
with
i i've got some i've i've been the
victim of targeted dislike campaigns
some recent shows in fact i think of
mine have like
tens of thousands of thumbs down
and again initially when i when i would
see something that i'd laugh about it
but then i realized that no i'm a victim
here
i should take the opportunity to be the
victim
so remember if you're if you're watching
this right now on youtube remember to
remember to smash that like button
not the dislike button you bigot think
about my emotional well-being
before you hit that dislike all right
number four chelsea handler
noted scholar had this to say on twitter
she said uh it's so pathetic that
there's a trial to prove that derek
chovin killed george floyd
when there's video of him doing so it's
pathetic
it's pathetic that we're still doing
trials in this country
ridiculous but twitter's already decided
that he's guilty why can't that be
enough
now she's getting um there's there's a
bit of a targeted dislike campaign going
against that tweet right now and i'm
sure she's a victim of that
because people are responding to it in a
negative way as well they should
but she's only being honest about about
what the media feels and
and uh and how people on the left feel
about this in fact
here is uh lindsey davis on abc
she was talking about the george floyd
case
and her opinion she used she used
more words and different words but
really she came to the same conclusion
as chelsea hamlet let's listen this case
is so much bigger than what happened 10
months ago in the corner of 38th in
chicago in minneapolis
on its face derek chopin is on trial for
sure
but for many americans this nation is on
trial our criminal justice system is on
trial
and for many especially black people
this is about black and white this is
about
justice for people who aren't
specifically involved in this case
this is about justice for eric garner
and brianna taylor
and daniel prude and on and on and on
the countless black people who have been
killed by police in this country
with very little repercussions or or
punishment
and i think that that's what makes it
interesting when you look at the context
the backdrop of what also was happening
in this country
on may 25th of 2020 in new york city
central park it's the same day that a
white woman called the police on a black
man who was bird watching and said
threatened that she was gonna call and
follow through with that uh to say that
a black man is threatening my life so
what does that have to do with george
floyd the woman
woman called the cops on a guy who was
bird watching
what what does that have to do with
derrick chauvin being on trial
well it's because she feels exactly how
uh how chelsea handler feels
which is that we don't even need a trial
it because
it's it's not about derek shove and i
said this yesterday this is proof of uh
proofs in the pudding here
that from the left perspective in the
media's perspective and i don't know why
i list those two groups like they're two
different things
but from their perspective
um derek chauvin is
it's not about the facts of the case for
him it's not about what he did
or didn't do it's not about george floyd
it
derek chovin is a is a symbol
and you heard us say america is on trial
right racism is on track he's a symbol
for all of the things
they don't like they don't like america
so
this is he he symbolizes america he
symbolizes white people
he symbolizes all of the alleged and
perceived sins of whiteness
he symbolizes um every alleged or
actual white racist who has ever done
anything wrong
all of that is contained in the person
of derek chauvin
everything that makes up the actual
derrick shelvin all of his unique
traits and uh all the things that he did
or didn't do
that's that is emptied out we've kind of
hollowed him out
and in his place we have put
um all of this he's a sacrificial goat
right and they need him he's a
sacrificial goat and he needs to be
slaughtered
it's kind of like an actual sacrificial
goat you bring up to the altar
to sacrifice it's not because the goat
did anything wrong necessarily
it's about what the goat symbolizes and
he's the goat here
and there they are very clear about that
all right um chet hanks now we got now
we gotta get to the really important
stuff i've been waiting to talk about
this because
this to me is is the the biggest most
important thing happening in society
right now
chet hanks is the son of tom hanks um he
is or was a rapper i think at one point
and
now he's an actor i believe uh but
mostly he's a pioneer
and so for example he pioneered
something called white boy summer which
is picking up steam online
and uh you know i saw people talking
about it online i didn't know i don't
know what they were referring to
and you know and then and then i found
out that oh they're referring to what
chet hanks said and
i didn't know who chet hanks was and
then i had to look that up and i was i
was digging through
and i finally got to the videos where
chet hanks announces white boy summer
i still don't know what white boy summer
is even after watching the videos but i
thought i'd play them for you so that we
can all
join together and be confused together
so here's chet hanks announcing
white boy summer hey guys um look i just
wanted to tap in really quick i just got
this feeling man
um that this summer is uh
it's about to be a white boy summer you
know
take it how you want i'm not talking
about like trump uh
you know nascar type white i'm talking
about you know
you know me um john b
jack harlow type white boy summer you
know what i mean let me know if you guys
uh
can vibe with that and uh get ready
you know because i am i think i'm ready
i don't know i don't know who any of
those people are so
i'm a little suspicious he said it's not
a i'm not a big nascar guy either but
you know he's it doesn't really clear
he's just all he says is i
i got this feeling i got a feeling that
it's white boy summer that's all
what is white boy summer it's just a
feeling i had that's it and we're
it's it's happening what's happening i
don't know it just is
now later on as this conversation about
white boy summer
uh continued he recorded another video
giving some of the and so now it's
starting to clarify a little bit he's
giving some of the rules for white boy
summer and let's
listen to that oh wow wow wow
woke up this morning internet going mud
again um but
just want to drop a few uh rules and
regs
for the white boy summer okay rule
number one uh to all my white boys out
there
no plaid shirts okay can't be looking
like a picnic table out here boys
wait what you know what i'm talking
about leave that at home the uh
vineyard vines and you know okay ralph
lauren or
whatever something sold a bill of goods
let's put out a black tea a white tea
you know what i mean keep it simple uh
rule number two
no sperry topsiders that's not the kind
of white boys
we're talking about dog okay uh get
yourself some
vans some some jordans i'm not really
there's nobody's afraid of these shoes
feel it out i'm um there'll be more
rules coming oh yeah yeah
no calling girls smoke shows okay okay
that that term is uh it's played out
dude
and you can't something all right check
it out okay shut up chess
is this so this is what white boy summer
is just at is a bunch of rules that we
have to follow
that's what the summer is i thought i
thought i was expecting something a lot
more fun than that
you're just introducing more rules for
us you cannot call it white boy summer
and tell me no plaid
that that is not gonna fly that's not
gonna cut it
the rest of that i don't know what the
rest of that is so fine i can do without
it
maybe and i admit maybe the problem is
he's white boy summer i'm
i'm probably too old for white boys i
think he is too it looks like he's like
45
but um i i i will admit i'm too old uh
maybe it's more it's not really about
your chronological age it's about your
station in life
and as a father of four kids uh married
man i'm probably too old for white boy
summer which is why
i've decided i'm announcing and this is
pretty exciting
they can have white white boy summer i'm
i'm announcing white dad summer
um and white dad summer the uniform for
that very simple
you could do a polo or a t-shirt um and
you can go plaid
but the main thing is tucked into cargo
cargo shorts
new balances white new balance obviously
is gonna be the traditional
footwear of our people as white dads but
you can really go any color you want
um and you got the socks pulled up and
uh and then you got the sweat stained
ball cap which is
with the bent brim that you've had since
1993 that you still wear
and then the knock off oakley shades of
course
that is white dad summer that's why and
that and by the way that summer is in
full effect
in my house anyway all right let's move
on to i'm glad we were able to talk
about that and cover that let's move on
to
reading the youtube comments as from
ronnie says how can shoving possibly get
a fair trial when the city of
minneapolis
already admitted guilt by settling a
lawsuit and awarding the family millions
of dollars this has mistrial written all
over that's a very good question
yes not only is it is the trial still in
minneapolis and not being moved
to another city but this yeah exactly
the city has already
has already admitted guilt um and they
did that during the jury selection
process
so it's clear that
i talk about the left in the media
they're trying they want
they see chauvin as a symbol and he has
to pay the price
that's what the city sees him as also
he's he's a sacrificial goat as far as
they're concerned
um mike says could you explain your
stance on breaking up via text that's
not really a stance it's more of um
you know if if if if you've only been
dating
i know this is not a popular view but if
you've only been dating for a few months
or a few weeks or whatever and
and it's not working out like your
relationship
is so insignificant that it really does
you don't
need a whole long emotional conversation
and one of the problems is if you do the
long emotional conversation in person or
on the phone
uh that's when the other person might be
able to convince you
like you know this is not working at all
because it's a couple months into it and
already
i don't like you and so this is just
it's not going anywhere
but if you have a conversation other
person might be able to emotionally
blackmail you and convince you to stick
it out for a little bit longer
and just delay the heartbreak for later
so you know i'm obvious
they won't like it but it's the best for
everyone involved to just make it like a
band-aid
quick simple easy send the text message
you know
they're going to hate you for it but at
the same time it's probably better for
them anyway to
to hate you for it and they can move on
and uh and that's my
i'm not saying it's good advice but
that's simply my advice
um roland says
hi matt the phrase no cap means
something is true
or that the person who says it is not
lying cap means the opposite or not true
love the show what
no cap yeah someone said no cap
yesterday in the comments i didn't know
what that meant
no cap means something is true or that
the person who says it is
not lying cap means the opposite or not
true
why though this is this has been the
theme of this show i just i get older
and older as as we progress
here um and finally nicholas says
commenting for the algorithm
i will say nicholas you are not banned
for that you are the opposite you are
i don't know you are knighted you are a
knight of the matt walsh show for doing
that thank you for your service
and and by no that's that is that is the
main thing leave a comment smash the
like button
and uh and leave a comment it doesn't
matter what the comment is and if all if
that's all you're doing is leaving the
comment saying it's for the algorithm
i'm fine with that
thank you for your service to the show
it is an honor
we've been talking recently about gun
rights and the attacks on gun rights so
the tax on our constitutional rights in
general which there's been quite a lot
of that unfortunately in the last year
especially
uh and as conservatives we always say
well we love the constitution we
want to defend the constitution yet how
many of us have taken the time to really
learn it and actually stand ready to
defend it that's why my friends over at
constitutioncoach.com
have a lot of great programs that you
should take advantage of for equipping
citizens to defend
liberty uh by studying and living out
the constitution
i experienced the constitutional defense
course myself
is one of the most worthwhile
experiences that i've had and you can
have the same experience you get an
amazing combination of intellectual
ammunition and live classes with rick
green
america's constitution coach and then
you also get the physical training at
the premier firearms training facility
in the nation
you're getting all this in the same
course right you get to join hundreds of
other patriots from across the nation
for a time of learning and training and
fellowship with like-minded people it's
a really important part of this is the
fellowship
whether you've shotguns your whole life
or if you've never touched one or if
you're somewhere in between
doesn't matter this is for you these
people they took me to a whole new level
uh skill level and they'll do the same
for you they'll do the same for anyone
so don't just get a gun learn how to
carry with confidence and get the
training you need to defend your family
go to constitutioncoach.com
rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but
it'll fill up pretty fast so
visit constitutioncoach.com today and
watch my video there to find out more
about how you can be a part of this
one-of-a-kind training that's
constitutioncoach.com
as you probably heard candace joined the
daily wire a few weeks ago uh with the
premiere of her new talk show candace
the show streams on dailywire.com
fridays at 9pm eastern but you can get
the audio podcast
candice on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast
featured guests they've they've a lot of
different guests jaco willink brandon
tatum john rich to name a few
candace is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live audience
but don't worry if you can't attend the
show in person you can still submit your
questions to
at the candace show on twitter um join
and uh
and also of course you can become a
daily wire member you've got to become a
delegate remember if you want to watch
the whole show
use code candace and make sure you do
that now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today of our daily cancellation i'm not
sure who exactly is getting cancelled
but i do know
what i want to complain about um we'll
figure out the rest as we go along so
this past weekend i went to the zoo with
my wife and kids along with my niece and
nephew and brother and sister-in-law we
had six kids seven and under
four adults um one of the adults was
pushing a stroller another
one my brother-in-law was carrying
around a fussy one-year-old and i was
hampered because of the soft pretzel and
cheese dip that i was trying to eat as
we walked along
now it's um it's very hard to keep track
of six children in this environment
especially with the soft pretzel and
cheese dip
so you have to constantly do the count
right you're going one two
three four five we're missing one
where's the other oh there he is hey no
stop climbing that fence there's a tiger
in there
and to make matters worse as your kids
are running around this way and that
you're noticing
that the meerkats and monkeys all have
better behaved children than you do
they're looking at you shaking their
heads with disapproval but then i
noticed
a woman with what appeared to be just
one child
walking him along on a leash and the
leash was attached to the kid's backpack
making it slightly less aggressive and
noticeable than the harnesses they used
to attach directly to kids bodies back
in the old days
i saw this and i thought the same thing
that i always think on the rare occasion
that i encounter a leashed child in
modern society
and that is wow that looks so much
easier i totally understand why that
parent is doing that
but i can't do it because i don't want
to endure the glares from other parents
see as parents we all know that the
child leash makes a lot of sense
we've all looked with a mixture of awe
and envy at the parents with leashes
we've all thought to ourselves i get it
i do i get it
but that we don't say that though
because if we notice another parent is
also looking
instead we'll turn to them and say out
loud sheesh
she's got a leash on that kid pretty
awful right what a weirdo i would never
do that
and we all walk away speaking our
forbidden pro-leash truth
silently in our hearts as i said back in
the old days this wasn't an issue
parents used to
leash kids all the time i distinctly
remember being five or six years old
and uh you know seeing other kids
walking around the park tethered to
their parents it was totally normal
then at some point in the last 20 years
or so we decided that this is now
unacceptable many parenting shortcuts
have been deemed problematic
and somehow negligent or abusive in
recent years just in time
for me to not get to use them playpens
are another
back when i was a young child kids were
put into pens
much like barn animals for hours at a
time
you didn't have to worry about your
one-year-old running through the house
swallowing quarters sticking their
fingers into outlets falling down the
steps
you just had to put them in the cage i
mean the you know the the detainment
facility
and uh and and sit down and drink your
beer
it was that simple but nobody uses play
pens anymore
so many other examples come mine again
when i was a kid i vividly remember
being left in the car
often and for long stretches while my
mom
ran into the grocery store we would get
left with like uh
snacks and a sleeping bag in case it
gets late she made sure that the
temperature was comfortable obviously we
weren't left in a 95 degree vehicle
but then she would run and do her errand
that we would wait in the car it was
totally
normal again everyone did it but now
leaving your child in a car for even
two minutes no matter how cool it is
outside
or what precautions you take is
considered an act of unthinkable neglect
if you do that now people say you left
your child in a car
what in a car parents these days are
afraid to leave their kids alone in a
car while they walk
12 feet away to put their shopping cart
back or at least that's the excuse they
always give me
for leaving the cart there's no reason
for this
a child in a locked car on a cool day in
a shopping center parking lot
is perfectly safe it might be one of the
safest places for him
oh you might be kidnapped well he's just
as likely to be kidnapped in that
circumstance as he is to be kidnapped
out of his room at night
which is to say it almost certainly will
not happen and almost never has happened
almost never you hear about the cases
when it happens because it almost never
does
yet we've decided to make life a little
harder for parents on this
in this area for no reason car seats
another example
do you know they expect you to keep a
kid in a car seat until he's like five
now
and then you switch to a booster seat
until he graduates college
and the car seats are not so much car
seats as they are seats salvaged from
rocket ships
they're massive heavy impossible to
install and they restrict the child's
movement so much so that he's guaranteed
to cry and whine for the whole nine hour
drive to the beach
when i was a kid you know what what
putting a kid in a car
then you you just you opened the door
and said get in and the kid got in and
buckled themselves that was it my
parents had me in the front seat no car
seat no booster seat
when i was like four with the middle
seat in the front i would sit there
he just jumped in the car and took off
they have to spend 45 minutes getting
everyone locked in like we're about to
blast off on our way to a settlement on
mars or something
it was easier back then for parents
fewer rules less shame less of a chance
that cps would knock on your door
because your neighbor reported you
for allowing your eight-year-old to ride
his bike down down to the playground by
himself
that's the way it was it's not that way
anymore in conclusion
woe is me who am i canceling
i guess everyone who has made parenting
this complicated
which includes myself because like i
said i do join in the shaming of the
leash
kids and or the parents who use leashes
even though i sort of envy them
so i'm a prop part of the problem um but
i don't cancel myself i can't sell
everybody else and boomers also for
having it so damned easy
you don't know how easy you had it you
don't know what it's like now for us
so everyone's canceled that's it um
and i guess we'll leave it there for
today nice note to leave it on
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21 criminal
coyotes flourish
ferrying foreign nationals across our
southern border republican matt gates
considers leaving congress amid a sex
scandal investigation
and big tech tries to take out stephen
crowder check it out
on the michael knowles show